Two controllers, one runs on every node, one runs once and stops.
The demon set ensures every node in your cluster runs a copy of a pod.
Add a node, a pod appears, remove a node, it's gone.
Log shippers, monitoring agents, network plugins, cube proxy, infrastructure that has to live
everywhere.
That's a demon set.
A job creates pods and runs until a specified number completes successfully.
Not a service, a task with a finished line.
Batch processing, data migration, machine learning training runs.
Retries on failure, delete the job, pods are cleaned up.
Need it on a schedule, that's a cran job.
Demon set runs everywhere, job runs once.
Different tools for different shapes of work.
On the docks, Kubernetes, demon sets and jobs.